i think the in the next 30 years this
country is going to be christian
conservative
so um it's an example i've given before
but for the context i'll say it again
in the early 2000s a survey was done it
found that liberals were having i think
1.54 kids or something like that on
average and conservatives are having
2.01
that meant that conservatives were at
replacement levels and liberals weren't
20 years later we get this poll that
shows or about 20 years later 18 years
that uh gen z is slightly more
conservative than millennials but only
slightly they're very very similar and a
lot of people assumed that meant that
gen z was based that they were waking up
that the culture war message was getting
to them but that's not reality the
reality is conservatives just had more
kids ergo more conservative gen z that's
it simple meth so what we see from the
left is an attempt to indoctrinate kids
because leftists don't have children
they have yours
now we're seeing them attempt to get red
states to enact an abortion abortion
rights because they want republicans to
abort their kids
otherwise what you get
right now today the left is
substantially more likely to not have
kids like the i was looking at a graph
and it's like it's plummeted but
conservatives are actually fairly stable
though it has gone down
just give it 18 more years 18 years from
today it's going to be 2040. we're all
going to still be
we're going to be
middle-aged
and we're going to be seeing a
substantially more conservative country
yeah but i don't think it's going to be
christian conservative yeah i will i
doubt it dude ancient religions are on
their way out hand that rocks the cradle
rules the world but that's right yeah
bro yeah but sense nonsense okay maybe
maybe a muslim way i don't know i've
been here for 2 000 years i know time
man
well nonsense
nonsense fades away it's been two
thousand years what's going on it got
rewritten like five times
which one was it
when by who and what did
literally proven him correct about what
statement he didn't even he says it
persists and nonsense fades away but it
also became the orthodox church it's
obvious that the romans are are the
patriarchy like the roman catholic
church was created to suppress and
control people and you're praying what
you were saying about marriage they're
proving demonizes children born out of
wedlock you've proved sheamus's point
there he wasn't making a point he was we
were just having a conversation what he
made a point what what we're just now
i said because christians are having
children more than the left the future
will be christian conservative yeah but
that's james said one plus one equals
two argument that's not how humans works
said the hand that cradle rocks the
world and you you disagreed and said
it's fading away then you went on to say
that despite all of the things that
happened throughout history
the religion persisted and evolved and
was changed and all of that whether it's
true or not you're arguing that instead
of fading out and dying it was
reinvigorated and re-embraced and
expanded to the point where it's bigger
than it's ever been throughout history
because there was universal truth
beneath the sins
there was a truth that that persisted
throughout the ages beneath the sins and
in the same way
the
sins of the roman empire are not an
indictment of god the sins of our
founding fathers are not an indictment
of america
there there is a difference between
ideas and the application of those ideas
and then this is something that even
conservatives have had trouble trying to
articulate to people who don't
necessarily believe in god
many people who don't believe in god
don't necessarily believe in a
traditional view of america or american
citizenship and it is a great infowar
slavery is not an indictment of
america's foundational values in fact
the constitution was used to justify
freeing the slaves so it actually
vindicates that our constitution and our
american founding values were were
brilliant and and were inclusive in in
some ways and were humane but the
application of them in the early stages
was certainly not but but those things
aren't an indictment of the ideas
uh themselves and the i and certainly
not an indictment of god
well i know a lot of people that call
themselves christian that go to church
and then they get wasted and like you
[ __ ] your body's a temple really like
is that that's the point
you want to say that you're completely
true and that they'll just go like like
christians don't need to worship christ
you don't need to worship jesus to be a
christian does it say not to drink beer
in the bible no so yeah you you cannot
drink to the point of excess you can't
go wrong which is to say yeah which is
to say you can't drink to the point
where you are no longer able to make
good decisions right and how insane like
come on that's like the biggest
hypocrite as his criticism of like
modern culture people call them so
christian and they destroy themselves
like come on well all yeah i mean look
there have been hypocrites in the
christian faith throughout all of
history judas is one of the the first
bishops right and he betrayed christ
i don't know that's all ancient text
stuff man i don't know if it's real or
not 230 to 250 million americans are
christian
and so
i think one important point is that
while the percentage may be lower than
it was before
of people there are still substantially
more christians
i'm a christian and i i've taught god as
much as anybody who comes on here
probably uh somewhat but
um i agree with you ian
my point's not even not even to bring up
religion in the first place my point was
that as as sheamus said the hand that uh
people who identify as christian
conservatives are going to be the
majority identify but i agree with you
when you say
that a lot of people who say they're
christian
don't necessarily follow the laws of the
faith
uh so yeah they're just like there's a
referendum on what it means to be
american if we even want to have a
country and that is the referendum right
now do we want to have a country there's
a referendum on christianity and what it
means to be christian what it means to
be catholic they're having that argument
in the vatican right now there is going
to be an ongoing argument about what it
means to be or identify with these
institutions and these cultural beliefs
uh again that's not an indictment of the
beliefs themselves it's it's it's an
indictment of man's application of
belief i think the that the ideals of
christianity are impossible to embody
i i i i'm
the the argument about religion itself
is is is not relevant to the point i'm
trying to make the point i'm trying to
make is that
christians are having children whether
they truly believe in the bible is
totally immaterial what matters is the
left ideology will die because they
don't have kids therefore they argue for
red states where there are more
christians to have abortion access
because that will result in more
christians having abortions whether or
not they believe in there's going to be
there's going to be some young christian
girl who's like i don't have a baby i
don't have i'm going to go do it
if it's illegal she's going to go to her
parents and say what do i do and they're
gonna say we're gonna support you you're
gonna have the baby this is the i think
a a big reason whether
they're conscious of it or not there are
probably people on the left who realize
since the 2000s we have slowly been
eroding the the leftist movement has
been eroded they're tr they i mean
if you look at a lot of the left
movements it's always been about
eradicating religion
but they're losing because they don't
have kids the so this is why the school
choice fight is so
important for the democrats they can't
allow people to take their kids out of
schools and choose where they want to go
this is why they're freaking out over
the supreme court decision in maine that
allows people to get public funding and
choose whatever school they want release
or otherwise this is why they're
freaking out about a coach who prayed
for himself and students decided they
wanted to pray with him they said no
he's leading them in prayer no he was
praying they also decided to pray people
are allowed to speak you can't stop them
or fire them from doing it they're
losing
they're not having kids and with the
internet
christians christian conservatives or
even hypocritical christian
conservatives if they call themselves
that still are
expanding growing and defending their
values defending their kids is also why
they're so freaked out about the don't
say gay lie
because they're like we need to
indoctrinate their kids because we don't
have any and this is why they're
screaming don't say pray universal laws
and and the real scary part is in my
opinion it's a stop gap
because if the lgbtq-ism indoctrination
doesn't work
they're going to be the ones who abandon
the idea of democracy
the fastest believe that the push for
artificial intelligence and this whole
automation driven transhumanism
idea
is the
um
is the
uh plan b you could say uh no pun
intended it's the plan b for if the
indoctrination doesn't work and in the
automation ai world there will be no
more democracy and that's what they plan
on doing and that's what you see
um many many factions of our government
doing right now and going after
conservatives like steve bannon it's
just we're going to create a banana
republic where the ideas of justice
democracy freedom are completely
relative and we'll make them up as we go
yeah it feels like um we are headed
towards a more conservative future if we
do this right like things have gotten
way too wacky and like
ready for change you know at a drop of a
hat like we need to conserve our values
but the only the reason i brought up
that i don't think it'll be a christian
conservative is because i think people
are bastardizing the word christian
calling themselves christian on paper
going sitting in a church repeating
words but they don't live like i think
you're well but you have to i think i
think you're biased i think you have a
negative view from immediate depictions
of what of what a christian is
maybe you might be right about that
because like of the christians we've had
here has any one of them have been in
any way as you've described it
well everyone's like no one's perfect
yeah what drinks you know i mean yeah
but like i don't care being a christian
being christian isn't principal and
drinking is not a sweet as long as
you're not drinking access you're
getting drunk shameless you tell me if
i'm wrong but my concept of being
christian fundamentally is
do you believe in sin or don't you
i mean that's one of the that's one of
the anchors and so when you say that
there are christians who people who
identify as christian who are hypocrites
the the distinction there is that they
believe in sin and they may be sinning
but they do believe that it is a sin and
that there's a a metaphysical accounting
that they can then be redeemed from by
by having faith or by asking for
repentance and people who don't believe
they don't believe in a metaphysical
accounting and it's kind of uh most of
them believe in karma which is the same
thing essentially but they you know but
some people don't believe in
universal accounting at all and that's
dangerous i think they're they're
obviously fake christians there are
people who claim to support a lot of
ideas they don't support there's a lot
of people who are like who are woke who
say they hate racism but then they're
super racist there are a lot of people
who claim to be christian and you see
these videos of them you know screaming
and spitting on people i also think that
there is a media depiction of a
christian this is just outright not true
of all of the religious people we've had
come here not a single one of them was
as you described oh i mean we sit with
people for an hour and a half i don't
know those people yeah sure what do they
think about when they're alone in their
room at night like i don't know but
they've not screamed at you they've not
uh you you've not witnessed any of them
be as you've described christianity as
hell it's a really weird thing you're
supposed to be like this benevolent
angelic thing that has no sin you've
washed away what we believe or you're
just guilty about right no no no no no
no no no no no no no no and this is just
training the catholic church like
you sit in front of sheamus all the time
and you say things like this is what
it's supposed to be but you've never
bothered to actually sit down with
sheamus and ask him what he believes
well i mean so much james believes that
when he drinks wine and eats bread it's
literally the body of jesus christ yeah
well i'm not
eating one and drinking bed in that
instance but yeah no i do believe in
transubstantiation i believe in the the
holy eucharist i do like that so there's
no say that but you know one thing
that's not relevant to the point i'm
making the point is that it's not you
cannot a piece of bread is not literally
a human being
the point i'm making
is that sheamus does believe that and he
is not lying about what he believes and
you consistently depict christians as
like rabid
you're saying
hey kid this bread is literally a human
body the kid's gonna be like i don't
believe that that's that's not what
we're talking about well you're saying
kids are christian parents are gonna
have christian kids that's not how it
works when you lie to your kid and tell
them something is what it's not the kid
sees through it that's not true so ian
there there's a couple things that kids
are impressed
impressed upon by their parents and
adopt their parents values and there's
just a there's a few things i want to
mention because there's something i
really want to touch on here to be
christian
there's two tears here right you're sort
of discussing hypocrisy and hypocrisy is
a real phenomena but there's a
difference between being someone who
makes a mistake and sins which everyone
does and christians acknowledge that and
we call ourselves sinner and and someone
who says i actually don't believe this
is a sin i'm going to do it anyway while
calling myself christians now you
insinuated earlier that i'm a hypocrite
because i drink even though nothing in
my faith prohibits drinking as long as
you're not getting drunk because you
don't know anything about my religion
you don't know what i believe because
you haven't take the time to ask me but
you were willing to make an accusation
about me in front of literally tens of
thousands of people i was told by a
catholic that i'm going to hell because
i don't believe jesus is the son does
that justify but does that justify any
of what i just said well i mean um
i don't know anything about your face
my point is you made an accusation
towards me which insane i don't know
what you're drinking kind of i've seen
you get somewhat drunk it's not that big
of a deal but i i've i think you you
drink to the point where you're you're
feeling a little bit like happy or
bubbly but you cannot drink to the point
where you're making bad decisions dude i
don't even care but the point is yeah
yeah yeah i care about people you
brought it up but you brought it up
exactly to insinuate that i'm a
hypocrite but you never stop to ask me
about any of this or what the faith
teaches and so i think that's really
unfair because we've known each other
for a long time and especially if there
is something you think i'm hypocritical
on then you have a conversation with a
person instead of waiting until you're
on air to try to make an accusation i
don't want to be part of everyone but i
then fair enough but i think what
matters most is
you've known christians who have said
and done things to you that have hurt
you and i yeah i think that stinks
because look christians are are human
beings and we also make mistakes i've
seen christians
all people for sure sure but but my
point is
we don't become christian because we
believe other christians are perfect we
become christian because we believe in
jesus christ we believe that he's
perfect
that doesn't require but it doesn't
require believing that other people are
perfect that doesn't require being a
perfect person but the whole like
believing that jesus is not what makes
you anointed it doesn't give you the
power of annotation like so i believe
that i got to stop you because this
conversation is not going anywhere the
point i made was ian
you you've asserted something about
christians that has not
appeared before you out of the entire
time we've done the show and had
numerous christians come on talking
about their faith
my question is
how could you believe in a a general
negative depiction of all christians or
or a large sum of them or a majority of
them or a plurality when you've not
encountered any of those stereotypes and
any of the christians that we've had
come here and not just the people who've
been on the show but even people who
work here
that's what i don't know i've seen like
christians behave cruelly
cruelty people christians that are
lustful i've seen christians that are
and get angry which is wrath which is a
sin
um
you can ask in what context is getting
angry at saying roth what wrath yeah so
wrath does not exclude
wrath does not um condemn
righteous indignation there are things
we should be angry about so you
basically are saying that
being angry at all is sinful and makes
christian hypocrite but again you don't
know what christians believe about anger
or wrath the the point is is just this
you've you've made several points on
several different shows
about christians generally being this
hypocritical or negative thing even
though
at the very least you could argue there
are you know you've actually met more
christians who are nice and do adhere to
their faith than who don't
but you still maintain the negative over
the positive i usually have good
interactions with people in general
because that's what i give people when i
enter i i just feel like if 250 million
people in this country identify as
christians
i don't think most of those people are
hypocritical i don't think i don't
really care how i think it
it doesn't make you a christian that
doesn't make you a good person yeah
not everyone who calls lord lord will be
saved but shame as you would you would
agree with this and and i think there
are many catholic theologians and devout
christians who are much much more
in alignment when they're with their
faith in in their everyday life than i
surely am that would
tell you
uh ian that
the decay of america or the decay of
society is the failure of the church
yeah
and 100 the hypocrisy of the church and
that that them not being the the moral
shepherd that they were supposed to be
in in a variety of ways
is partially and or mostly to blame for
how wayward society has has gotten um so
no nobody who is
again what what i think what tim is
trying to say is that
nobody who's really christian who has a
well-formulated
world view on christianity is trying to
abnegate the culpability of christians
in the
the wayward ways of the world at all i
think most christians in fact who are
real christians and not just virtue
signaling like the left does will tell
you no christians are actually to blame
for for how things have gotten i'll put
it this way kind of what i'm saying is i
grew up catholic i went to church what i
saw of christians
depicted on tv didn't make sense to me
because i did not know anybody at my
church who acted that way as the as the
media would would portray them
ian you've also not been to church have
you a few times yeah like you've
actually
when i was younger i went uh i went to
an outdoor catholic church once i went
to a methodist church once i went to a
youth group for often every sunday i
would go like for three hours the people
there were generally just mean kids and
they would play basketball so so i think
that's the example of it uh i see how
the left depicts christians i see how
jordan clepper and comedy central goes
to events and finds people to
characterize and mock and portray
negatively and then i think about the
people i met growing up then i think
about how i had this moment in my life
where our church actually kind of
slighted my family and my family stepped
away from them made me a bit angry and
it felt like these people were lying and
then i met someone who wasn't christian
who talked to me about jesus and i was
like oh
they were just bad people yeah people
and then i realized something as i
started to travel around i remember
being at occupy wall street and seeing a
conservative pro-life protest and they
were all like oh man we're going to go
there be careful we're infiltrating
that's what the left said we showed as
much of old ladies waving american flags
and they were waving and smiling and i
was like no these people are mean and
then i hear people
give general negative depictions of of
religious people i'm like i wonder if
that's just a negative media portrayal
stereotype because if 250 million people
in this country identify as christians
certainly not 250 million people are
walking around angry or hypocritical in
fact not even the majority or plurality
of them are
typically angry at least when you see
them in person on twitter yeah they've
probably got that angst and anger but
for the most part when you go outside
and touch grass the people you're
talking to probably christian and not
all that mean actually kind of nice if
you collapse in the middle of the street
in the middle of anywhere in this
country someone's going to run up and
try and help you for the most part in
some places they don't but what i mean
to say is
regardless of the religion i just think
it's absurd to characterize and
stereotype people as generally negative
and hold that view of them hypocrites
because people will tell me
they'll be like dude it doesn't matter
what i do i can do whatever i want
because if i believe in jesus he
forgives me when i die i've never said
that yeah kids growing up they were
taught by their parents from the church
they're like oh all all my sins will be
forgiven if i believe in jesus children
other like friends high school kids and
whatever that's part of the reason why
it's a sin and that's part of the reason
why it's a sin and egregious to kill a
baby in the womb
because
because
children
don't have a uh
what what what aquinas did
what he did for christianity what what
christianity solved was a merger between
uh
judaism you could say
and first principles of of greek and uh
uh aristotelian thought and it and and
the catholic belief the modern catholic
belief is that the holy spirit doesn't
exist in and of itself necessarily that
it is embodied and perfected with the
human
rational mind
and that to live and to think to have
thought to know god is actually the the
height and strive of christian and
catholic belief and when you rob a fetus
of their growth and maturity and faith
that is the ultimate sin
you've taken the innocence of a child
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there